CBS sports college football studio
analyst but more importantly a musician
a songwriter Oh a singer-songwriter it's
been a long time since I've been here
too with song well we were told that you
weren't allowed to play your guitar any
it was uh I was not allowed but in this
last but I created you I understand and
that was exactly the pitch I gave to the
brass at CBS and they sold Tom Parker
and your Elvis well with apologies to
Elvis and anybody who is affiliated with
Elvis but and also to Colonel Tom Parker
but no they said you know what you can
do it Thank You CBS we appreciate that
in ten minutes he'll have his a DP show
related song he joins his courtesy
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
let me start with the hit last night
Trevathan on right Davante Adams you
have targeting in college football and
the use of replay
why have targeting or the potential for
targeting call and no replay in the NFL
well they with 45 active players they
don't want to be eliminating one of
their best players from the game so they
just throw a 15-yard penalty but as the
game Canuck comes under more scrutiny
with more stuff on CTE and so forth I
think that move will be made I think
ultimately they'll borrow from the
college rule and change it there needs
to be some still tweaks to the college
rules it only impacts defensive players
you never see a running back get called
for it when he puts his head down and
creates the helmet-to-helmet contact but
and when people are trying to get to a
line of scrimmage a first down or
something and diving and we're heads
naturally are gonna collide that
probably should be eliminated from the
call but safety has got to be a
paramount importance I mean it has to be
because of we got to get young kids to
want to play again knowing what you know
now your your kids played would you have
them play if they were if they were
younger you know that I was always of
the mind when they're that age no one's
running fast enough to get hurt anyway
you know they just kind of big you know
Michelin men you got to running into
each other right and so I always thought
it was safe but now that these studies
are coming back and and and truthfully
the coaches
that youth age didn't know enough to not
do the helmet-to-helmet stuff you know
we used to have the board drills and
what they call the oklahoma drill where
people get on either side of a board and
try to drive the other guy off well that
contact starts with head low man wins
right so that had to be changed that and
I think it is getting changed but if I
were king for a day I would say no one
needs to wear pads till they get to high
school and I can tell you I really
believe that you do not need to practice
in pads to play a great game of football
I mean tackling may suffer blocking may
suffer but it would suffer across the
board and we would get rid of the
chronic part of CTE you wouldn't be
hitting all the time would you have your
kids play football oh absolutely
okay you learn great lessons from
football and you can get hurt in lots of
different ways and riding a bike but
yeah I think football is a wonderful
game I think it's and the great thing
about it especially youth ages every
body type can play you know you not
everybody gets to play hoops not
everybody gets to play baseball but in
in in football regardless of your
coordination regardless your body type
you can be on a team and get all the
lessons that come from being a teammate
explain to the audience you were a
quarterback whisperer you studied it you
played it you look at Mitchell true
Biscay right and where he is with the
team you now what are you waiting for
what are you trying to prevent him from
experience the school of thought I think
is that you don't want to damage his
psyche right you don't want to put him
in there before he's ready to go and it
is a quantum leap from college football
as it's played with the rpoS and all
that's going on although you saw him
creeping in last night that touchdown
pass Aaron Rodgers first touchdown pass
was clearly an RPO probably should have
been flagged but you want him to be
completely ready so that his confidence
isn't damaged when he gets out there and
sees this myriad of coverages and myriad
of blitzes and finds himself in harm's
way that being said I think now that
you've invested this much in him I think
a Mitchell true Biscay can benefit by
getting in there and I think the Bears
organization can benefit in particular
John Fox can benefit because now you can
give John Fox a pass because they're
bringing along a young quarterback when
you go and spend a 15 million dollars or
whatever the number was I'm Mike Glennon
assuming that you did all the research
and all the
evaluation and then he goes and throws
balls over guys heads like it's going
out of style last night the organization
looks bad so I think we're gonna sleep
for Biscay but with Jared golf did the
Rams do the right thing I didn't think
they had the right head coach for Jared
golf now you do moreover and you know I
was a golf guy we talked about yes when
golf and Wentz were in the marketplace
moreover what they did right is they got
only one voice what was going on with
the Rams when golf got there there were
about five different guys in his ear you
know whether it was Winkie or or the
head coach or whomever they were all
telling him something else trying to you
know well this is what that meant here
was the language at Cal here's the
language now with the Rams here's what
this means and but five different guys
hey I think you should be doing this
when you have too many voices in a
quarterbacks ear he doesn't know who to
follow who did not trust so he goes back
to I'm gonna do it the way I do it
and that can be a disaster well Fisher's
not an offensive minded head coach right
now you bring in McVeigh who is right
you bring in some weapons for him get
the offensive I mean this is no secret
if you have that much talent I got to
have a good offensive line do I have any
weapons and I got an offensive minded
head coach so we're seeing progress here
and what else can help and I think Mike
Shanahan did this with RG three when he
was a rookie with the Redskins you bring
a little bit of what he did in college
bring a little bit and bring a little
bit of that language
everybody's so hell-bent on saying hey
we've got to call it every word in this
play call they did that with Cam Newton
in Carolina exactly get in look at the
numbers he produced as a rookie if you
give him some comfort zone where all
sudden I know what I'm doing rather than
I'm wondering what I'm doing a guy can
blossom try Biscay was an excellent
player in in college as an accurate
passer he was an 84% passer before he
got the starting job I go I don't care
if you're pulp stone against air if
you're 84% you're pretty good okay and
and then obviously he blossomed and you
started looking at the athlete that he
was and when he got to the combine I
mean he goes all the way up the charts
to number two I think you can get true
Biscay some seasoning now and I think
the organization will feel better about
the future but I look at the
quarterbacking position and we were all
in on Kaepernick and our g3 cam yeah
and then
something happens something happens
where you sit there and say what and
I've got two theories on it one
obviously the nfl's faster in terms of
its defense people ask all that all the
time
how do people not get open oh they get
opens Rascals on the other side can hit
and can close ground and so you take
some hits but if you're doing the zone
reading you're getting outside as we saw
Kaepernick enjoy success with the Niners
that that's risk free sometimes you get
a little bit over your skis and you
start getting quarterback powers which
was the Cam Newton exercise we saw it at
Auburn for a Heisman Trophy and then he
was doing it so well with Carolina
ultimately they didn't use it in the
Superbowl which is still curious to me
but at the end of the day those guys are
getting a lot of people in the ears
going hey the money is in the second
contract you don't want to run so much
Vince Young who was brilliant in college
and needed his legs to be brilliant in
the NFL was telling Norm Chow who is the
coordinator at Tennessee at the time I
don't want to run anymore
well that was coming from his agent
whose needs him to be upright so that he
can Inc the deal which is the big money
in the second he wasn't a good enough
passer no no you know those guys can't
live and I say those guys the guys who
have find ways to impact defenses with
both their arms and their legs aren't
good enough to play against the
coverages that exist when they know the
legs aren't part of it but when you see
Brady now we we all see the greatest
quarterback of all time but not
everybody would have seen that and in
the embryonic stages here so what what
is it about Brady that ultimate
competitiveness ultimate competitiveness
very very acute I I mean brilliant IQ
for football in terms and Manning would
be in this company I think Aaron Rodgers
as I watch him play Rodgers has got the
most beautiful arm talent you've ever
seen but they what they do is they do
see that when he was at Cal you don't
know it because that most coaches in
college don't allow you to do it
they just say do my play and then I'll
send you another one they don't let guys
change out of plays
we are retarding the the development of
quarterbacks at the collegiate level
because we're doing it for them
everything's up tempo fast pace get up
to the line of scrimmage look over and
I'll tell you where to go
you're never really gleaning anything
from the defense and if you don't know
what's going on in that defense you're
behind the eight ball when you get to
the NFL the other thing and I want to
talk some college football we'll take a
break and I want to have you give us
your latest DP show related song one
thing I've noticed is the inability to
develop offensive linemen to go into the
NFL 100% the college game is not
developing so we're not talking but
where is the high school game the high
school games gone to the spread I mean
the the spread offense was developed
because Art Briles when he was a high
school coach and others similarly
situated looked around and say have no
big guys there's no guys so we can't
play that way so we're gonna play out on
the edges get the wide receivers as
close to the to the sidelines as they
can if they go out with us now we've got
a box that we can work in and we'll be
able to survive but there are not enough
offensive linemen who know how to come
out of a three-point stance who know all
the different fundamentals I work with
Randy cross at at CBS is law as well as
Aaron Taylor these guys have a constant
dialogue about how bad the fundamentals
are in the collegiate ranks and it
starts in the high school ranks and so
just as we talked about a halfway house
for quarterbacks between the the
collegiate level and professional level
I think offensive lineman needed as well
he's Rick Neuheisel will come back I
want to ask you about these college
quarterbacks including USC UCLA who
would he take right now if he had to
make it or I'll let you have Josh
Allen's from Wyoming you're gonna give
me you want me to answer now I'm
learning this bit yeah and you got your
guitar with you so we'll come back we'll
talk some college football with Rick
Neuheisel
right after this
[Music]
how about the checkerboards of tennessee
we've even got our own USC we bought the
Aggies and misery just a little sampling
there that's rick neuheisel of course
unplugged I logged his right one of his
early hits born in the SEC and CBS
college football analyst joining us here
in the man cave joining us courtesy of
cotton little tire Coaches Corner
before we get to your guitar Sam darn
old started off slow this year why well
the running game is not up to snuff with
the exception of the game against
Stanford where they had 200 yard backs
and went for over 300 yards which put
made everybody feel like s/he was back
because they struggled a little bit
against Western Michigan they were less
than 2 yards to carry against Texas and
less than 4 yards a carry against Cal
and Cal was like 127th and defense last
year in the country so Justin Wilcox
doing a nice job there but Darnell needs
a running game to go with him and
they're still fitting some new pieces in
on that offensive line he may have a
little bit too much of an infatuation
with Deonte Burnett they all everything
receiver there and that might be causing
him to focus too much on him but I don't
worry about Sam Darnell he has it
there's things that you you're not gonna
marvel at when he gets the combine if
you he just wears a number that doesn't
say Donald on the back just the number
of combine you know because your meat on
the hoof there his ball is not going to
come off you're gonna go high that guy's
but he has what you look for when it
comes down to 45 seconds left and no
timeouts to go down there get you a
field goal there was a play in that game
where he had to leap from the point made
the play I mean that that's sensational
stuff he has it darn 'old will be a
big-time player if you had to take a
pick nailed Arnold or rosin I'm leaning
rosin and and I didn't want it you know
rosin that's not UCLA loyalty is well no
no it's a matter of fact I wanted rosin
not to be good because my son was trying
to win the booth I kept going he isn't
I mean my son was trying to get the job
but I kept going Jerry
he's pretty sorry son he's got every row
that Rosen has every throw and that come
back
yeah he got fortunate trying to throw
one away and end up being a touchdown in
a different type of attitude than Donald
he's the kind of guy dan that he wants
to know why you gonna tell me here's
what the progression why and if you're
not equipped as a coach to answer it and
answer it adequately so he understands
it thoroughly he's gonna keep probing
you and that's gonna wear some coaches
out but Rogers has to be like that too
with Green Bay I mean he strikes me as
you know I don't know Aaron well enough
to know that but clearly he's very
cerebral and but remember this he also
got to sit behind a guy who was gonna do
it in a myriad of ways Brett Favre was
anything but you know by-the-book and so
he probably sat there and goes well why
aren't you doing it this way there was
probably a lot of when I get this job
here's how I'm gonna do it and he's been
brilliant but I think Rosen has the real
stuff I know there are gonna be people
are gonna be hands-off because of his
personality and he's flamboyant and how
important is football to him right he
was a tennis kid and you know that but I
think based on the way he's performed
and his ability to whip it around the
yard and put it wherever he wants to I
think he's gonna be really good what
about Alan at Wyoming I think it's
unfair to Josh Alan because we put him
so quickly in the carson wentz category
same coaching staff Craig Bohl gonna be
coaching it and and when you see a
unicorn you know there's another one
right they and so I think people jumped
on that bandwagon a little too soon I
would hope from my perspective that Josh
owl would stay one more year and season
just a little more certainly got the
body you know like the old Brady Bunch
Johnny Bravo you fit the suit you know
he fits the suit but but I I would say
that he needs just a little bit more
seasoning as we notice him to power five
games Iowa and Oregon not very didn't
look good yeah with what's going on with
basketball with recruiting scandal there
Wow I know it's it's easier to because
of the shoe companies to get a kid pay a
kid and he only need one
to change your franchise you know you
can't do the same in football although
you can go after cleats aren't the same
marketplace hey gimme give me the
recruiting story you don't have to name
names but give me the recruiting story
to let the audience know I got all crazy
they got this from first hand you know
when I got fired at the University of
Washington I went and worked at Rainier
Beach High School and one of the kids on
our team was a basketball savant you
know and one day he asked for a ride
home from practice
that's it sure so he jumps in the car
and I said where I said I I'm figuring
it's got to be a mile two miles away
high school right 40 miles later I got
him home and in that forty miles I asked
him how in the heck did you end up at
Rainier Beach and I got the long story
of the AAU the coaches leading leading
him on oh and bundling to this AAU team
funneling him to this particular place
telling him where he's gonna go to
college Edo he was already committed at
that time to a major university and
there was a lot of influence and a lot
of people along the way and I'm not
gonna get into what the numbers were but
clearly hands in the pot what is he
getting paid I didn't get there I didn't
I didn't really want to know but clearly
there was an incentive for him to go 40
miles to go to high school and to play
on this AAU team it didn't did he play
football football he ended up being a
football player I kept trying to tell
him you're gonna be an unbelievable
outside linebacker and I still believe
to this day that he would have been but
the basketball thing was already done
and matter of fact he tweaked his ankle
the next week and was told by the head
coach in college basketball no more
football he was told no uncertain terms
there had to be some reason some some
some leverage and get that thing done
because he loved football I get your
guitar ready yes Rick Neuheisel CBS
college football studio analyst song
aren't singer/songwriter he's sort of
our resident James Taylor here what's
your inspiration with this song the
country country since since I've been
away since we haven't had songs I mean
what the heck's going on ER I don't know
blame you bring us
yeah I think I think that you needed me
here bring us all together Rick here
apologies to the great Dolly Parton
under a DP DP DP DP look at all that's
happened since I'm gone
DP DP DP DP more than never now you need
my song oh sure it started as just funny
with songs like born in the sec but now
I realize it's so much more since I've
been gone all hell's broken loose from
White House visits to freeing the juice
it's time we get the order restored
presidential tweets a bad idea as the
NFL in North Korea and the FBI is
posting on the blog those charged will
sing like golden birds the shoe
companies will be undeterred and coach
Pitino will weigh in that he shocked
this is supposed to be footballs time of
year DP DP DP DP how soon can we get
this all in the rearview mirror the
national anthem is center stage who
stands who kneels is all the rage and
constant dialogue who's right and wrong
for those who've taken a history test
our country was founded on protest keep
it peaceful and let's learn to get along
if you're thinking that you're just too
tired with the presidents who says
you're fired
think of images so recently folks
helping folks after hurricane wins
without a care of the color of their
skin or that is who we truly want to be
come on DP DP DP
you and I can help but fix what's wrong
we just need someone with talent to sing
the song I'm sorry we just need someone
a talent to sing this song once again
once again man he's back and better than
ever
great seemeth always a blast thank you
thank you the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience